[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu füttern acht dem
top der schlagzeilen macht ich bin voll
ronzheimer ich war vor vielen monaten
das letzte mal in deutschland denn ich
war in der ukraine drei monate lang
kriegsberichterstattung heute möchte ich
mit meinen gästen über diesen krieg
diskutieren und das insbesondere mit
menschen mit politikern die nicht meiner
meinung sind denn das ist das was
viertel nach acht ausmacht viele
meinungen und eine kontroverse debatte
und der mann der hier neben mir sitzt
ralf stegner er ist der anti waffen man
der spd zumindest eine zeit lang und er
legt sich besonders gerne mit dem
ukrainischen botschafter an ralf stegner
ist als linksaußen und
bundestagsabgeordneter der spd um die
prozent bei uns und bei vielen anderen
medien mit dabei oberst a d ralf thiele
er ist der militärexperte und wird uns
sagen können wie lange dieser krieg
wirklich dauern könnte und was der
westen jetzt tun muss um die ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen und sie werden es
nicht glauben es geht noch linke als
ralf stegner nämlich bei klaus ernst er
ist linken abgeordneter wütet gegen die
nato die ukraine und alles was dazu
gehört und wir wollen von ihm wissen ob
ihm seine aussagen niemals peinlich
waren und wieder kriegsverlauf
weitergeht neben ihm jürgen hardt cdu
außenpolitiker das letzte mal als wir
uns getroffen haben hier vor
kriegsbeginn da hat er bereits waffen
gefordert und ist auch jetzt klarer
unterstützer von der ukrainischen
regierung er kritisiert kanzlers scholz
für seine zauber haltung beginnen möchte
ich aber mit dem thema das uns heute
bewegt nämlich die frage was mit einer
möglichen nato mitgliedschaft von
finnland und schweden passiert herr
stegner herr erdogan hat sich geäußert
diese finnland nicht in die nato haben
sie sorge dass das passieren könnte nein
ich glaube am ende werde man sich
verständigen nach finnland und schweden
sind beides
befreundete staaten die schon lange
kooperieren die eigentlich auch schon
lange mit arbeiten und wir kennen ja
herrn erdogan was vieler dahinter ist
ein schwieriger partner in der nato und
der wird auch ein paar wünsche haben ist
meine vermutung und er glaubt dass er
die besser erfüllt bekommt wenn er noch
ein bisschen auf den putz haut das tut
da gerade
meine hauptsorge hab ich glaube es am
ende wird es dazu führen dass das was
die meisten wollen nämlich dass schweden
und finnland mit hilfe der nato das ist
auch geschieht herr ernst die müssen
sich ja jetzt sehr nah mit herrn erdogan
fühlen denn sie wollen auch dass sie
waren auch nicht dass finnland in die
nato kommt glauben sie erdogan will das
verhindern also erstens von ihrem
vorsprung ich hab dann ging gegen die
nato gewettert dies wäre mir neu dass
ich dich sagt ich glaube das ist
ansichtssache ernst die einen sagen so
die anderen so gnädig ehefrau gitta
fakten und die zweite ich glaube dass
europa nicht sicherer wird wenn wir mehr
direkte grenzen zwischen nato und
russland haben vor dem krieg nicht und
nach dem krieg nicht und es kommt dazu
dass wir ja nun da gibt es ja schöne
filmchen ist auch zu sehen ist im
fernsehen woher genscher verspricht es
gibt keine ausweitung der nato die haben
wir erlebt und jetzt geht sie weiter
sicherer macht es glaube ich die welt
nicht er hat glauben sie dass wladimir
putin genug truppen hätte um finnland
und schweden richtig angst zu machen
oder sind die so zertrümmert durch den
ukraine krieg dass wir von diesen
drohungen nichts mehr zu befürchten
haben das gehört ja zu den großen fehler
einschätzung putins besser die eigenen
streitkräfte total überschätzt hat das
hat damit zu tun dass sie genauso
korrupt sind wieder ganz so startet das
wenn dort der camel beschließt viel geld
für munition auszugeben anschließend die
generale und die rüstungshersteller
vermutlich die beute teilen und nur
wenig munition für die pro paar wirklich
einkaufen das ist ein spiegelbild der
russischen gesellschaft unter dieser
oder des russischen staates unter dieser
gruppen kleptokraten führung von putin
und ich glaube dass wir akut keine angst
haben müssen auch nicht im baltikum ich
möchte zu einem arzt nur sagen nicht nur
die nato wird sicher sondern vor allem
natürlich schweden und finnland und die
finden und die schweden haben mit
breitester mehrheit entschieden dass sie
das wollen
mitglied zu werden wir haben den
kritiker von paris von 1990 die übrigen
diese wird und nun mit unterschrieben
hat wo bündnisfreiheit drin ist und ich
glaube dass wir gut daran tun die finden
und die schwedin zügig aufzunehmen ich
gehe davon aus dass das auf dem nato
gipfel ende juni ist glaube ich
stattfinden wird und dies unterstütze
das und ich bin dafür dass der deutsche
bundestag das ratz fatz dann auch
ratifiziert dass wir eines der ersten
länder sind die das tun aber diese sorge
ist ja immer irgendwie da immer wenn wir
über die frage sprechen ob die nato
ausgeweitet wird wenn wir über die
ukraine krieg sprechen immer dann gibt
es die vermeintliche sorge dass putin
weiter eskalieren könnte er steht
rechnet sie damit dass er irgendwann
sagt okay jetzt werfe ich eine taktische
atombombe so einfach kann man sich das
nicht machen im übrigen das nato
hausleitung natürlich ein weitläufiger
begriff hier reden wir über
skandinavische länder über nachbarn die
seit vielen vielen jahren mit uns
zusammenarbeiten das ist etwas anderes
als wir den wünschen anderen die nato
offen und sie wissen ja die bedingungen
die nato aufgenommen zu werden ist ja
einerseits dass sein land das will und
zwar geschlossen will großer mehrheit
hier in finnland schweden und anderes
als dass die bedingungen erfüllt sind
dass sie auch aufgenommen werden kann
das ist bei finden und trainieren nun
eindeutig der fall da gibt's ja gar kein
argument dagegen das ist bei anderen
ländern nicht der fall ich glaube in der
tat am ende auch dass man immer auch
darauf achten muss dass wir nicht nur
den unseren freunden in der ukraine
helfen so gut wir das können sondern
dass er immer auch darauf achten dass
der krieg nicht sich ausweitet und die
nato daran glaubt vielleicht neue stehen
dann hätte oberst ziele wir fragen uns
natürlich auch was kommen dafür zwei
armeen jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich dazu
also hilft uns das hilft das der nato
die finnische armee die schwedische
armee und dann wie schätzen sie das
eskalationspotenzial von russischer
seite ein jetzt in den nächsten wochen
oder monaten so lange es dauern wird bis
man dann in der nato ist da zu versuchen
die beiden davon abzuhalten
wir haben eigentlich schon immer sehr
gut zusammengearbeitet mit dem finden
und den schweden ich erinnere mich schon
an regelmäßige besuche in schweden in
den 90er jahren seitdem sind beide
länder immer wieder dabei wir sind
interoperabel miteinander es ist
geradezu so dass beide in modernen
ausrüstung modernen einsatzfeldern
besser ausgerüstet sind als wir ich habe
das bei partnerschafts gipfelten erlebt
dass sie ein bisschen ungeduldig waren
mit der innovation der nato streitkräfte
an für sich also wir erleben jetzt hier
erstmal generell sehr moderne
wegweisende ausgerichtete streitkräfte
die zudem wenn sie das total defense
force konzept der der zähne nehmen auch
ein sehr modernes verteidigungskonzept
hat das uns vielleicht auch viel
richtung geben kann in der zukunft wenn
wir uns mit mit russland und vielleicht
auch china auseinandersetzen müssen was
er kann gut drauf setzen wenn ich das
gerade noch sagen darf na gut die
konventionellen streitkräfte sind ihm
jetzt etwas ausgegangen da wird kaum
etwas kommen von der seite was wir
natürlich eben tatsächlich nicht außer
acht lassen sollten wir hören das
relativ selten unserer diskussion das
sind die hyperschall waffen das ist
einfach unglaublich gefährlich
unglaublich schnell wir haben so etwas
nicht im westen wir können das auch
nicht abwehren also von daher kann er
doch immer mal wieder eine eskalation
draufsetzen aber und wie schätzen sie
ist eine teletest zum beispiel die
wladimir putin bislang sich nicht dazu
entschlossen hat truppen zum beispiel an
die finnische lange finnische grenze zu
schicken heißt es er hat keine mehrfach
nicht alle in der ukraine kämpfen und
tod sind oder liegt es daran dass er
vermeintlich nicht weiter eskalieren
wird weil in wahrheit erreicht er jetzt
genau das gegenteil von dem was er immer
wollte nämlich mehr länder werden
mitglied der nato
das ist der super-gau für ihn also ganz
ganz klar ich glaub das ist fast
schlimmer was jetzt passiert mit
schweden und finnland insbesondere als
das was in der ukraine schon schlimmes
aus seiner perspektive mit ihnen
passieren dass er sich nicht durchsetzen
kann da würde er dran grübel das wird
auch an seiner machtbasis wurde in
russland weil er ihr klar russischen
staatsinteressen nicht im ernst wenn sie
das hören was die analyse an die
militärische analyse auch eben dass die
truppen zu geschwächt sind und es jetzt
dazu kommt dass oder sehr wahrscheinlich
dazu kommt wenn erdogan sich am ende
dazu bereit erklärt dass viele donato
aufgenommen werden was bedeutet dass aus
ihrer sicht werde jetzt erstmal bedeutet
dass sie auf eis gelegt wurde auch bei
den abkommen dass man gesagt hat kein
land so ist eine sicherheit auf kosten
als andere cent anderen landes erhöhen
und selbstständig wird putin dies als
problem begreifen
mein name ist ernst ist es ich bin jetzt
dran so und es bedeutet das ist
natürlich
als einen akt begreifen könnte der seine
sicherheit bedroht ich denke nicht dass
dies dazu führt dass putin in finnland
oder in einem anderen land der nato die
dann in der nato wären angreift die
nachricht also mit militärischen mitteln
des verhindern wird das würde auch nicht
tun aus meiner sicht aber das problem
ist ja die frage muss man stellen alle
miteinander werden durch diese schritte
wird europa durch diese schöne sicherer
oder ist es eher eine weitere stufe die
uns auseinander treibt und die damit
risiken in der zukunft bringt und das
ist meine meinung ich denke die zukunfts
risiken werden durch so einen hand
größer und nicht kleiner also ich finde
es richtig dass man das alles abwägen
und bedenken muss weil wir tatsächlich
in dieser situation nicht sagen können
was ist jetzt der richtige schritt ich
möchte gern ja zu der beinahe die 2008
verhindert haben dass die ukraine in die
nato aufgenommen wurde brauchen sie
jetzt dafür damals hatten wir nicht nur
wir sondern auch andere bedenken davor
dass wir eben diesen schritt unternehmen
ohne dass es seitens russlands ein
anlass dafür gegeben hat und damals 2008
aber wann reden fehler im nachhinein an
den krieg glaube wahrscheinlich glaube
dass auch eine stärkere rüstung der
ukraine vielleicht das risiko für putin
das zu erleiden was er jetzt erlebt hat
auch sichtbarer gemacht hätte und wir so
vielleicht auch ein angriff verhindern
hätten können das haben die amerikaner
demokraten wie republikaner jahrelang
gefordert wir haben dagegen gehalten
weil wir der meinung waren militärisch
weil man das nicht eskalieren aber ich
möchte eine these hier
komplett widerlegen aus meiner sicht ich
glaube das potenzial überhaupt nicht
bedroht fühlt 0 bedroht wird das ist die
legende die er erzählt mit der meint
sein volk aufputschen zu müssen gegen
andere staaten wie zum beispiel ukraine
denn wenn er tatsächlich von der nato
bedroht fühlen würde wird er nicht einen
großen teil seiner streitkräfte in
dieser vergleichsweise strategisch und
wichtigen ukraine frage investieren dann
würden seine generale ihm sagen du musst
die truppen bereit halten für den fall
dass die nato die gelegenheit nutzt und
uns angreift und er hat vielleicht ein
finalist rechnen muss brauche auch keine
angst davor zu haben das findet in der
nacht bekommt hat er auch nicht er hat
keine angst vor der nacht und das ist
eine legende die er seinem volk war ralf
stegner der ja als ein politiker galt
der besonders häufig premier putin
verteidigt hat und das was in russland
passiert ist und ich habe
nicht ein einziges mal verteidigt weil
ich keine sympathie für otto karten habe
ist ein kriegsverbrecher der dna ich
gehöre allerdings zu den leuten die
sagen das ist spekulation man muss
teilweise sich in die perspektive von
anderen versetzen auch wenn man deren
perspektive nicht teilt putin hat sich
getäuscht als sie getäuscht in der nato
die ist mitnichten hirntod wie über uns
mal gesagt hat sondern die hat sich
zusammengefunden die europäische einheit
ist so groß wie sie schon ganz lange
nicht gewesen ist hat er sich getäuscht
hat sich getäuscht in den militärischen
zielen trotzdem ist spekulation an
sondern auch die russen sich jetzt
bedroht fühlen oder nicht wenn kein
psychologe ich weiß dass nicht ich kann
nur sagen wir sind freunde wir wissen
das aber telefonieren sie manchmal mit
leuten die wissen wie man weiß nicht was
die klischees auch was die vorhin gesagt
ich würde mich gern mit dem kubanischen
botschaft bestreiten ich habe das
gegenteil gesagt ich habe es aber wir
sollten innenpolitische diskussion nicht
mit botschaftern führen das ist nicht
deren aufgabe sondern dieser diplomatie
machen wir streiten untereinander was
ich denn auch aus russland von ihren
früheren kontakt was machen kann ich
kann nur sagen dass es das
bedrohungsgefühl gibt auf der einen auf
der anderen seite das kann man nicht
wegreden mit rationalität weil bedrohung
ist was subjektives und ich will das
beispiel nennen was in der konstellation
anders war aber trotzdem etwas verrät
auch keine idee hat gelernt das hat
damals nämlich den dritten weltkrieg
verhindert in der kubakrise gegen den
rat von journalisten wissenschaftlern
militärisch moment wirtschaftlichen als
politisches statement das ist wichtig
ist wenn man in der außenpolitik mit
gegnern zu tun hat ist dass man nicht
ihre perspektive teilen muss dass man
aber nachvollziehen muss wie die denken
könnten das hat keine idee getan hat
eine sehr kluge haltung klug sind nicht
die die die wildesten interviews geben
klug sind nicht die die härtesten
forderung haben so ein klug sind die
einerseits unsere freunde verteidigen
glauben und leben durchaus wohnen
interviews und ein anderer sei
und andererseits darauf achten dass auch
die sicherheit des eigenen landes der
bundeskanzler ist vereidigt schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuwenden das tut er was
die zögerlichkeit nennen nennig
besonnenheit in die bürger auf der
straße finden das uns auch gut da können
sie reden so viel sie wollen sich die
umfragen an die beiden heute
sonnabendmorgen diese werte sind
erzählt der bürger wurde das goutieren
war sagte jähnigen ich weiß nicht ob die
auf deutschen straßen unterwegs sind
aber wenn sie da sind und leute schauen
mir die repräsentativen umfragen
umfragen haben war nicht sie auch dass
die mehrheit der bürger geht das ist
schon eine nachricht dass nicht bei uns
ernst olaf scholz gegenteil hinter ja
recht dass die mehrheit der bürger gegen
schwere waffen für die ukraine sind
jedenfalls nicht für besondere und wenn
sie dafür und wenn sie genau hin und
wenn sie genau hinschauen und behörden
hat selbst der kanzler gesagt hoppla wir
müssen aufpassen also ich so gerne klaus
kühn ralf stegners doch li na
im kanzleramt oder den stoiber im
kanzleramt oder gar dass man kann sagen
dann sage ich ihm die antwort lautet ja
sorgt
wir müssen aufpassen ist könnte zu einem
atomkrieg führen kann hat der autor
heute das stichwort ich möchte einmal
noch ein den experten sozusagen in die
runde nehmen der so ein bisschen lächelt
über das glaube ich was hier diskutiert
wird ich weiß ich wie es interpretieren
kann herr oberst wenn sie das hören die
militärische debatte oder die
strategiedebatte was will putin was will
putin nicht und er ernst hat gerade
erneut die gefahr eines atomkrieges
benannt dass hier eine mannschaft
bezogen eine kanzler hatte
in interviews wobei man sagen muss der
kanzler hat an irgendwas nächste dame
und die ablehnung von schweren waffen
begründet und wenige tage später dann
sich für diese schweren waffen
entschieden was ist ihre analyse
also erst noch mal zu dieser frage mit
putin dahin mein lächeln sozusagen an
fühlt er sich bedroht oder nicht gross
möchte
man sich immer bedroht da können sie
gucken auch amerika wenn man den näher
rückt oder tina in der ausscheidung wenn
man den näher rückt großmächte ist das
immer unangenehm ein anderer näher kommt
also das ist mal da und genscher damit
bricht sozusagen eine neue partei hier
in die runde genscher sagte man muss
sich auch in die schuhe das anderen
stellen können ich glaube damit ist
grundsätzlich mit allrad über einige der
der seine sicherheit wahrnehmen wird so
mit nuklearmächten muss man vorsichtiger
umgehen die werden alle pfleglicher
behandelt das gilt auch für israel oder
auch für pakistan also wir können dann
nennen iran unsere große sorge was da
ist das ist nur noch wer bei dem man
schauen muss ich glaube natürlich weder
putin ein bisschen dann wird um uns zu
erschrecken und damit auch seinen
psychologischen
informationskrieg ziehen wie er verfolgt
uns angst zu machen aber dennoch
erwartet man natürlich von seiner
politischen führung dass sie diese dinge
hinter reichelt reflektiert und ein
eigenes politisches handeln übersetzte
was immer das dann im detail eisenmarkt
aber für wahrscheinlich halten sie jetzt
dieses szenario und ihre vage das ist
ein einen atomwaffen einsatz geben
könnte also vor den kulissen wieder
gesagt das ist alles undenkbar hinter
den kulissen können sie bei manchen
nationen hören ich rede jetzt nicht von
deutschland dass das bereits eingepreist
dass die
taktisch
natürlich ist aber auch ziemlich schräg
es stimmt also kein großer krieg sondern
eben die frage wie würde putin damit
umgehen wenn er jetzt im don was richtig
in bedrängnis kommt würde er dann ein
zeichen setzen dann gibt es den einen
oder anderen planer der eigentlich damit
rechnet der wunderschön so kleine
szenarien vor augen hat entweder über
über mehr oder gleich auf und bei der
ost ukraine
also so etwas gibt es und bin darüber
nachgedacht wird dann denke ich steht es
uns deutschen auch in europa gut an aber
auch nachzudenken das heißt aber nicht
gleich hasenfüßig davonzulaufen
nachdenken dann gebe ich die frau direkt
weiter jürgen hardt in der
unionsfraktion wenn sie da in der
fraktion zusammen sitzen und mit
friedrich merz diskutieren der ja einer
der wenigen politiker
war der nach kiew gefahren ist der erste
politiker
diskutieren sie darüber die frage eines
atomausstiegs
also wir diskutieren in der fraktion
intensiv über die frage und ich glaube
das tun alle bundestagsfraktionen weil
es für uns auch eine extrem belastende
situation ist wir sind in dieser
situation hineingeraten ohne dass wir
dafür etwas konnten wir machen uns
natürlich vorwürfe dass wir vielleicht
das ein oder andere hätten besser
vorhersehen können aber es bleibt dabei
putin ist aggressor und ich komme mit
meiner fraktion zum ergebnis dass es das
beste für uns alle wäre wenn es der
ukraine gelingen würde putin ein zweites
mal eine blutige nase zu verpassen um es
etwas salopp zu formulieren und die man
ein weiteres mal nach erfolgreicher also
eine seine militärische strategie durch
zu durchkreuzen ihn also einen sieg
nicht zu können und das könnte dazu
führen dass putin an einen punkt kommt
wo er selbst einschätzt ist es besser zu
verhandeln auch wenn er vielleicht nicht
alle seine ziele durchsetzen kann als
diesen krieg mit unwägbar am ausgang
fortzusetzen das halte ich für das
wahrscheinlichste szenario ich kann
nicht sagen dass es so kommt aber das
halte ich für das wahrscheinlichste
szenario und deswegen finde ich diese
waffenlieferungen total wichtig und das
wäre für uns alle das beste wenn das so
käme und deutschland und europa sollte
bereit stehen dann auch in einem solchen
verhandlungsprozess zur seite zu stehen
allerdings müssten dafür die waffen
schweigen ich kann ich nicht akzeptieren
dass man verhandelt auf der einen seite
und auf der anderen seite werden
menschen umgebracht ich kann mich
erinnern vor ein bisschen mehr als drei
monaten mittlerweile als ich mich auf
den weg gemacht habe in die ukraine das
war zehn tage ungefähr vor dem krieg
oder 14 tage wir sind in die ost ukraine
gefahren als der krieg ausbrach dann
richtung kiew und haben dann zwei monate
dort in kiel verbracht und stündlich und
täglich gab es die anrufe panische
anrufe auch von diplomaten die gesagt
haben wir müssen jetzt sofort verlassen
weil russland innerhalb von 72 stunden
dort sieht man auch bilder von meinem
gesprächen dort unter anderem mit
präsident ski während der zeit des
krieges das ist der platz dort von wo
wir berichtet haben mit vitali klitschko
aber was ich sagen wollte ist
das ist
diese warnung gab und alle fest davon
überzeugt waren dass kiew fallen würde
also erst hat man gesagt man darf keine
waffen liefern und putin nicht zu
provozieren dann hat man gesagt man darf
keine waffen liefern weil die ukraine in
jedem fall verlieren wird und jetzt sagt
man naja aber im osten da wird man schon
gewinnen erstehen da muss man nicht
sagen dass eigentlich alle experten in
ihren analysen und auch politiker falsch
lagen ich bin kein experte ich kann nur
sagen dies in der tat haben sich die
dinge geändert viele haben sich
getäuscht das sagt ja trotzdem noch
nichts darüber aus und so dann fand ich
das eben ja sehr besonderes hier gesagt
worden ist dass man wüsste wie die
andere seite reagiert und sie haben über
uns gesagt scholz habe das vor dem
atomkrieg darum interview davon geredet
habe erst mit den gleichen argumenten
schwere waffen was immer das sei
verweigert um sie dann zu machen auch
das ist nicht richtig sollen
entschuldigung auch das ist nicht vieles
wird behaupten was nicht stimmt dass
merkel ja jetzt starten wir die listen
lächelt mich jetzt auch stehen aber da
man korrigieren aber äußerst irgendwohin
wo er vor dem leeren ich war olaf scholz
hat gesagt wenn ich das sagen darf
deutschland handelt gemeinsam mit den
verbündeten insbesondere in washington
und in paris macht keine alleingänge das
heißt ja wir sportler fahren machen dies
das oder jenes das können wir nicht tun
wir haben auch manche formen der ukraine
nicht erfüllt zum beispiel
flugverbotszonen zu machen wir das die
nato involviert hättest wäre nicht
verantwortbar gewesen das ist keine
verantwortbare hilfe und ich gebe dazu
habe das nie daraus gemacht ich mir
schwer tue damit es den waffen liefern
ich kann es bis zum gewissen grad
nachvollziehen weil die ukraine sich
dafür selbst verteidigen können muss
aber dass man nicht sagt wir liefern
jetzt einfach eine schwere und immer
schwerere waffen nacheinander sondern
dass man das abwägt und zwar fall für
fall abwägen gemeinsam mit den
verbündeten das ist eben der unterschied
zu herrn merz der markt zwar nach kiew
reisen wunderbar aber der hat nicht die
verantwortung der kann sich auch
täuschen in seiner einschätzung die
leute müssen sich verlassen können dass
der kanzler den sie gewählt haben nicht
nur der ukraine so gut hilft jeder kann
gemeinsam mit den verbündeten und
deutschland viel mehr als behauptet wird
wird dafür immer bestimmt was ich
eigentlich finde ich wenn ich mir die
listen angucken die ich einsehen darf
als abgeordneter sind hier regelmäßig
anders als das öffnen darüber aber
richtig berichten sie uns gerne
herrschte krank ist das ist geheim
frankreich gesagt du bist gar nichts
darüber was sie liefern aus guten
gründen und wird dafür gar nicht
kritisiert ich will damit nur sagen die
besonnenheit dass man hilft so gut man
kann aber nicht in jedem moment so und
nicht jene immer nur schaffen aber
schnell wirklich so gut wie wir können
was wir gehört weil die gebhard sind
immer noch nicht geliefert es gibt keine
munition
das problem ist momentan im donbass dass
die ukraine dort eben im osten massiv
unter druck gerät und nicht in die
offensive kommt und dadurch dass man
immer nur ein bisschen liefert und eben
nicht mehr liefert bedeutet das ja auch
dass ein krieg in diesem fall ja einen
gewissen stillstand erreicht sozusagen
und beide parteien sich bekriegen aber
keine von beiden parteien gewinnen kann
herr ernst lieben wir sie erst mal einig
dass wir die dass wir uns nicht in
diesen krieg involviert lassen dadurch
sind sich einig sie würden gerne dass
die nato mit eingeholt ich bin dazu ich
bin der meinung dass deutschland viel
früher und entschiedener waffen hätte
liefern müssen genauso wie weitere
staaten um dafür zu sorgen dass russland
zurückgeschlagen wird das sozusagen der
angriff der russin inna lebende veraltet
so genannte keine nato kann den
nato-angriff das sieht man schon mal
einig aber sie wollen mehr waffen sie
wollen noch mehr waffen und sagen hätten
sie schon früher liefern soll wenn wir
jetzt noch mehr offen liefern dann
bedeutet doch dass ihr ergebnis dass wir
ein ziel verfolgen das bedeuten würde
dass sie der auffassung sind russland
muss diesen krieg verlieren natürlich
aus russland russland andere sagen
rösler mit verlaub mit verlaub aber wer
ein fremdes land über
aber
das wäre tatsächlich wenn russland den
krieg verlieren würde es gibt tolle
analytik die sorgenvollen des russland
darf den krieg nicht verlieren also
erstmal
integrieren ist es vielleicht mit einem
verminderten position halten dann wenn
dies eine vernünftige position ist komme
ich zu dem gedanken lassen sie uns doch
mal über lösung werden wir machen jetzt
noch nicht patenten online-lösung
möglichkeiten nachdenken vielleicht
verlassen mario wäre nicht gelang
gleichwohl sind lösungsmittel
unterscheiden entscheiden nicht für die
ukraine ist ein selbstständiger staat
wir haben auch keine vorschläge man das
machen die ich sage nur aber die
skorpione und zu den waffen der punkt
ist aber amerikanische präsident hat es
um das bestätigt anders als sein
verteidigungsminister vor das ziel ist
dass die ukraine den krieg nicht
verliert und russland ihn nicht gewählt
stehen das sind das ist den satz
unterschreiben die ukraine muss diesen
krieg gewinnen ich würde den satz
unterscheiden die ukraine darf der krieg
nicht viel ein wust an darf ihn nicht
gewinnen das ist mein satz die ukraine
darf ihn nicht verlieren woraus dann
darf ich nicht gewinnen also sie würden
den satz nicht unterschreiben die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen ich
glaube dass das nach allem was ich von
militärexperten höre ich bin keiner ich
fühlte dass noch mal hin zu schwer ist
zu behaupten man könne einen krieg gegen
eine nuklearmacht gewinnen nächste punkt
verlieren darf man sich nicht wir können
nicht zu das nicht aber das ist ja das
ist ja schon die fortschritte vorstellen
und leuchten nicht ich möchte nicht dass
ein diktat frieden gibt ich möchte nicht
das ganze nur verschoben werden noch
eines neuer imperialist ja schon
passiert da merkte man auch keiner sein
ich möchte das nicht möchte dass der für
seine kriegsverbrechen verurteilt wird
all das will ich auch und wir sollen der
ukraine bestmöglich helfen aber die
vorstellung man könne die in russland
betrachten die zweitgrößte atommacht das
haben wir verstanden
ist auch erstaunlich was es bedeuten
würde wenn dies so wäre ich sehr sehr
anders als sie aber auch vom gedanken ja
wusste jetzt bedeuten würde dass ein
kleines land soweit aufgerüstet wird
vermessen das ist eine art oben auch sie
heiligen können sie heißt wir haben im
bereich nicht mit größeren millionen
einwohnern für ein kleines land und mit
eines der flächengröße
sagt ja und die atomwaffen der ukraine
wurden 94 gegen sicherheitsgarantien
unter anderem der russen abgegeben hat
ja diese nutzen und sie heute ja das ist
aber dass sie jetzt den meditationen was
heißt ist wollen sie das dann
tatsächlich soweit die ukraine aufrüsten
wie es die ukraine russland besiegt ist
das jahr ist die russischen truppen aus
der ukraine fesche und das bedeutet auch
die krim im endeffekt glaube ich nicht
dass die krim momentan realistisch ist
ich glaube dass real hatte was wir tun
könnten doch schon eine lösung näher das
war das schon einen plan ist ja jetzt
mal was hieß es mit uns machen es ist
doch auch mal ganz nett anzuhören
also ich glaube hier geht halten
gehalten falls die diskussionsteilnehmer
hier das ernst in einer zukünftigen
leben dann wahrscheinlich auch
fernsehmoderator wird und damit herr
gysi gemeinsam und so eine talkshow
internet im neuen deutschland sieht dann
einen lauf aber
ich glaube wir ernst hat am meisten
erfolg wenn er das in moskau macht na ja
also werden sie dich und das habe den
sattel sieht den satz unterschreiben die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen ja
also ich halte es mit annalena baerbock
die hat gesagt der russland muss aus der
ukraine verschwinden erst dann kann
dieser krieg zu ende geführt werden und
kann einen friedensvertrag geben und das
ist eine bundeskanzler dede
außenministerin nicht nur von mir
sondern auch von unserer bundeskanzler
unglaublich toll ist aber dass das dem
widerspricht niemand ich sie müssen man
muss fairerweise auch genau zuhören wenn
man sagt die ukraine nach dem krieg
nicht verlieren heißt es auch mal
deutsch gesagt putin muss seine truppen
zurückziehen und aus der ukraine
verschwinden das ist die übersetzung
dieses satzes und auch so nicht sagen
sieg dann wenn ich sage russland nach
dem krieg nicht gewinnen dann meine ich
damit da darf jetzt nicht mit seinem
empolis muss erfolg haben grenzen
verschieden und frieden waren das ist
die übersetzung nur wenn man sagt die
ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen oder
muss ihn verlieren dann sind wir auch in
den bereich von dem die vorhin
gesprochen haben was machen wir denn
wenn tatsächlich eine taktische
atomwaffen eingesetzt wird irgendwo
wartet man zusehen getrieben ist und das
immerhin mit zu bedenken
dafür zu sorgen dass das nicht geschieht
nicht nur über waffen zu reden sondern
auch über diplomatie über
wirtschaftsfragen und über humanitäre
hilfen über all die dinge die auch
notwendig sind zu reden das ist der teil
den der bundeskanzler verträgt und
nebenbei merkel daher hat auch die
grünen und die fdp in der
bundesregierung dass man sich nämlich
einig in der bundesregierung hat sehr
viel klarer als ihre partei das wissen
wir auch dass jetzt schon so früh
natürlich hätte robert habe und an der
werburg gerne früher
in ordnung aber sieg und aber in der
bundesregierung ist man sich durchaus
sein sie sind dort neuerdings
militärexperte oder ich mach mich hat
nennen ich bin kein text für multi
ähnlicher mehr von uns hatten
wir und wir möchten die frage ob die
ukraine diesen krieg gerade wirklich
gewinnt und ob dieses land krieg
gewinnen kann das klären unter anderem
mit unserer militärexperten nach der
werbung
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter krach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen die damen und herren
bei
855 meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt tage
als freud oder schockiert
so nicht rüber chip buschi jörges will
wetten dass aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der darm führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten soll man den spaß und wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist
in der politik bei den journalisten
deren job ist es doch gerade abweichende
meinungen zu führen und sie sollen dem
doch auch richtig durch das tragen eines
konnte zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz
ein
doch das ist übliche an dem radträger
aus abgestritten ich habe mein beifahrer
meine sache immer bekommt er kümmert
sich darum niemand gibt es
auch darüber sprechen das ist einfach
nicht fair wenn ich richtig froh ist die
aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück zu finden
nachdem tochter schlagzeilen macht und
hier gab es bereits ja erhitzte
diskussionen darüber ob die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnen soll und wir
wollen einmal fragen ob die ukraine der
momentan diesen krieg möglicherweise
sogar gewinnt oder gerade gewinnt herr
oberst ziele wie bewerten sie die
militärische situation man muss
vielleicht einmal zusammenfassen das
ursprüngliche ziel von wladimir putin
kiew einzukreisen ist nicht erreicht
worden genauso wenig weitere große
städte wie aktiv und odessa und jetzt
konzentriert sich der krieg vor allem
auf den don was also dort die region wo
es schon seit 2014 einen krieg gibt so
muss man das sagen glauben sie dass
putin da momentan erfolge erzielen kann
und wie groß sind die
ja das thema erfolgen ich musste einen
kleinen ausritt machen in das thema
strategie wir sind gerade in einer finde
ich gefährlichen strategie diffusion
ball oder sieg das war ja gerade die
frage wollen wir dass die krainer siegen
diese sieg definition hat zwei
unterschiedliche enden das eine ist wir
wollen den status quo ante
wiederherstellen vielleicht ein bisschen
plus für die ukraine das heißt sie
vertreibt erfolgreich
putins truppen aus dem gebiet das sie
bisher eingenommen haben die amerikaner
haben eingeführt osten nach seinem
besuch in kiew wir wollen russland
dauerhaft schwächen das ist eine ganz
andere hausnummer dummerweise hat auch
url der wehr außenbeauftragte der eu
dieses topos mit aufgenommen aber das
muss ich dann muss ich direkt meine
erfahren was ist daran schlecht wenn man
sieht dass wladimir putin und seine
armee einen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine führt dass man in butter
kriegsverbrechen begeht das tausende
menschen sterben was ist aus unserer
definition dort aus unserer perspektive
heraus schlecht daran zu wollen dass
russland militärisch schwächer wird
weil wir damit sozusagen über die
ukraine hinaus gehen das heißt wir
verlieren das leid der ukraine aus den
augen wir legen unter umständen einen
langwierigen krieg an bei dem
insbesondere die ukraine leidtragender
ist natürlich viele andere in europa
drumherum auch das wäre bei einem
fokussierten einsatz in der ukraine die
wir ihnen bislang auch von der deutschen
seite werden treiben wäre das nicht der
fall es ist jetzt wenn man sich das
anschaut die oberländer aufgestellt mit
mehreren verteidigungslinien die
gepanzerten wachen dahinter wenn sie
dann ankommen und die munition wenn sie
dann ankommen könnte sicherstellen dass
auch durchbruch erfolge der russen
gekontert werden könnten als die ukraine
ist im augenblick sehr gut aufgestellt
tatsächlich dieses ziel für die ukraine
erreichen zu können wenn wir aber so zu
sagen welches ziel hat er jetzt meint
sie damit sozusagen die die grenzen vor
dem 24 februar also sozusagen die
russische armee dorthin zurück zu
drängen dorthin zurück zu drängen so zu
sagen wo sie herkamen ich will ich das
mal so bleibt sage das ist das richtig
doch genau das ist gut möglich aber wenn
wir darüber hinaus gehen das ist und da
ist dann die frage was ist das zum
beispiel sehen wir in letzter zeit schon
zunehmend auch angriffe auf russisches
territorium
das wird vor dem russen noch ein
bisschen klein gehalten die russen auf
der anderen seite gucken nach ob sie
nicht zumindest mit geheimdienst
operation hin nach polen rumänien hinein
zielen hier würde sich eine eskalation
abzeichnen die wir ja nicht wirklich
haben wollen also von daher ist wie
gesagt die frage der strategie was
wollen wir eigentlich was ist der sieg
der ukraine und ganz ganz wichtig und
meine empfehlung ist tatsächlich der
status quo ante + ich habe nichts
dagegen wenn die ukraine noch ein
bisschen mehr mitnimmt als sie vor dem
angriff hatte aber dass sowie meinen
dort zum beispiel und lohans die region
dass er genau dass das finde ich alles
in ordnung aber der punkt ist wir müssen
darüber auch reden und dementsprechend
müssten muss ja auch unsere bewaffnung
die wir dahin liefern diese so einem
ziel folgen dabei sind alle möglichen
ziele verfolgen immer wachenheim diva
hat eine ist eine letzte militär
strategische frage oberst wenn wir dann
putin betrachten und wir
psychologisieren da ja viel oder die
experten psychologisieren dafür mit
wieviel
käme er denn daraus und mit wieviel wäre
es immer noch das sagen könnte
ich habe jetzt hier in großen sieg
eingefahren weil nach dem verständnis
und wie propaganda funktioniert ist es
ja so dass er auch wenn er sich jetzt
zurückzöge sagen könnte ich habe die
ukrainische armee massiv geschwächt die
vermeintlichen nazis habe ich vertrieben
die sind alle getötet worden das könnte
ja ja mit hilfe seiner propaganda sender
immer so verkaufen oder er kann
sozusagen üben was er will aber wenn wir
jetzt objektiv noch mal hineinschauen
eher schlechte auch den westen wir reden
darüber jetzt nicht aber wirtschaftlich
kommen wir jetzt einen blick nicht
gerade als gehört darüber das heißt er
hat er hat er hat für seine baganda ihr
hat und auch für seine absichten die er
hat hatte er genug stoff um daraus einen
relativen sieg zu machen und das würde
ihn dann retten andersrum muss er sich
wirklich sorgen machen weiter bei der
macht zu bleiben was natürlich mit
fassung tragen würden aber seine
zielsetzung würde sicherlich seien
weiter im amt zu bleiben in einem satz
wie lange glauben sie wird der krieg
noch dauern ich fürchte er wird lange
dauern weil eben amerikaner russland
sprechen wollen und die russen den
besten sprechen wollen und die ukraine
dabei immer weniger eine rolle spielen
da sollten wir gegen wirken das wäre
mein war sehr hart man muss ja immer
wieder auch das vielleicht einmal klar
zu sehen dass die amerikaner vor
kriegsbeginn also vor dem 24 als
russland die ukraine angegriffen hat
keine schweren waffen in das land
geliefert haben und sehr versucht haben
immer wieder auch joe biden mit
gesprächen diese eskalation zu
verhindern also was glauben sie wie
lange wird dieser krieg jetzt dauern ich
fürchte auch dass wir da noch eine weile
mit diesen schrecklichen bilder leben
müssen ich glaube aber schon dass es
eine chance gibt dass wir an den punkt
kommen an dem protein sagt verhandeln es
besser als diesen krieg mit unwägbaren
ausgang weiter zu führen ich glaube
tatsächlich dass er noch nicht in der
situation ist dass er noch nicht
ausreichend geschwächt ist und ich
unterstütze die these des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministers dass das ziel
schon ist zu verhindern dass putin
weiter aggressiv gegen andere vorgehen
kann ich habe heute mit der vorsitzenden
ist europa ausschusses des georgischen
parlaments gesprochen georgien hat auch
zwei gebiete die von russland besetzten
die befürchten wenn putin der ukraine
keinen erfolg hat wird er einen
entlastungs erfolg erzielen wollen das
vergleichsweise schwach bewaffnet und
kleine georgien komplett besetzen das
ist die konkrete sorge toll geworden ich
finde das total brechen ich finde das
total wichtig der ist ja nicht in der
lage ist so etwas zu tun aber weder in
georgien noch in moldau waren wieder
chancen sich gegen
starken widerstand der amerikanische
präsident und auch davon tschechische
präsident teilen das nicht was dem
verteidigungsminister dort gesagt hat
sich das inzwischen korrigiert worden es
kann nicht darum gehen jetzt eine andere
großmacht zu schwächen die gefahren hat
ja unsere militärexperte gerade darin
die darin liegen unser ziel muss es sein
dass die ukraine diesen krieg nicht
verliert dass sie so schnell wie möglich
eine waffenruhe bekommen dass humanitäre
hilfe gibt dass man über wiederaufbau
verhandelt dass man putin an den
verhandlungstisch titel auch mit den
sanktionen das muss unser ziel sein
langer krieg und das ist der teil den
sie immer unterschlagen wenn sie sollen
wir die position karikieren die leute
wie ich haben ist die leidtragende des
krieges das er steht nach den frauen
wollen mir von pendler ich würde nicht
über die leiden einen dreiwöchigen krieg
sei aber die beste war doch die an meine
positionen die darin dass tatsächlich
doch das will ich mit meinem schuss
nicht dass er seine form findet dass ich
eine unterbrochene wie sagen nein sind
dann der kreistag in einmal jeder die
menschen im beschaulichen das material
muss ich einfach ausreden dass jeder
kriegstag mir eben zerstörung
vergewaltigen und vertreibung angst
hunger toso verletzte bedeutet und dass
man nämlich das beschäftige und ich sage
es verkraftbar nationalspieler ein rosa
weiter stärken als war das reden was in
porträts vertreter des landes der auch
länger gewaltig werden dass sie mit
lässigem der straße erschossen hat er
den letzten hat hunderte botschaften
lebens nur jahrhundert die
schrecklichsten kriegsfolgen
angerichteter den holocaust von
millionen menschen umgebracht und weiß
das ganze genau schon verhört worden
sind schauen anteilige diese kriegsheim
mit keinem schluss jetzt
verstärkt schauen sie sich das schon
wieder karikiert gar nicht so was ich
spreche von fakten und von dem was ich
in der ukraine gesehen hat sie kalt zu
lassen und mich auch mal ausreden wenn
sie in butter gewesen wären und gesehen
wie ich die leichen auf den straßen die
menschen die hingerichtet wurden das
sind die bilder die wir gefilmt und es
geht jetzt vor ernst genau sage ich
jetzt als erster reiter es geht weiter
russische soldaten ukrainische städte
einnehmen das ist der große unterschied
verlieren werden russische soldaten dort
herrschen und wenn sie sagen die ukraine
soll nicht mehr waffen bekommen und die
ukraine soll diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
dann passiert das was sie dort auch die
regel ganz in ihre waffen die sehen wir
wollen das verlängert dies ist leidlich
sie nein nein das war den waffen der
partei unter den jahr gesehen
aber wir sehen sie doch einmal vertreten
umso mehr menschen ständig wiederkehrend
mailand zurück weil sie es heute
versicherer halten als vor sechs oder
acht wochen die situation der menschen
in der ukraine in den teilen in denen
nicht gekämpft das ist eben ein
kleineres gebiet in dem jetzt gekämpft
hat gegenüber dem was vor sechs wochen
der fall war diese menschen fühlen sich
im augenblick gut geschützt durch
unterworfen und ich glaube dass das was
im augenblick geschieht mit westlicher
hilfe in diesem kampf ist besser als das
wie wenn putin mit seinem ersten anlauf
vom 24 februar richtung kiew inklusive
ist leider gar nicht wenn er erfolg
gehabt hätten dies
widerspreche der these dass es jetzt
schlimmer ist als es gewesen wäre wenn
wir nicht die waffen liefert je länger
ich klebe auch es so dass wir so wird
das leid das gefragt
am ende sei am ende des tages werden wir
heute nicht sagen können ob wir in einem
halben jahr noch sagen können dass es
richtig war dass man so gemacht habe ich
sage nur nach meiner einschätzung ist es
der bessere weg wenn wir es schaffen
dass die ukraine sich wirklich wehrhaft
gegenüber putin erweisen und ihm eine
blutige nase verpassen so dass sein
appetit darauf politische situationen
kriegerisch zu lösen deutlich abnimmt
das macht nämlich europa sicherer und
nicht gefahr kollege hat den ersten teil
dessen was ich gesagt habe unterstütze
ich nachdrücklich wir haben gemeinsam
gehandelt das war auch gut so das hat
der ukraine auch geholfen sich zu
verteidigen so stelle ich mir auch tue
was die waffen liefern ich sage aber
auch die logik die dann daraus folgt
russland zu schwächen oder so das ist
eben eine selbstlose militärexperte
sondern das gefühl ich muss vorsichtig
damit sein und das ist also das wollte
das will und ich möchte dass wir
wiederkommen zu konventioneller ab
posthum zu
das bedeutet ja eine militärische
schwächung wir müssen wir müssen den
euro zurück in die 90er jahre wo wir
diese großen abrüstungsschritte
hingekriegt haben aber den weg in die
abrüstung hat ja nicht der westen kaputt
gemacht sondern das hat ja protein
kaputt kann glauben dass da habe ich
noch nicht wohin ich mir vorher die
russen zu schwächen dass sie die machen
das können die zuse abrüstung nicht
zustande und die apulische spanien
kommen durch die nato nach
dies zustande gekommen weil verhandelt
wurde weil man gesagt hat welche
maßnahmen wollen wir treffen dass diese
gefahr eines atomkriegs sinkt momentan
haben wir eine eskalationsspirale dass
die gefahr eines atomkriegs er steigt
das ist durch das problem ich glaube ich
nicht das ist eine glaubensfrage
aber wenn es wenn es dann so weit kommt
können wir sagen sie haben uns geirrt
durch ist leider dann zu spät von der
frage dann auch umgekehrt wie lange
dieser ukraine dauern wird und die frage
was putin tun könnte und was er nicht
tut und was der westen tut es ist ja so
dass dieser krieg deutschland im griff
hat und auch aus anderer perspektive
nämlich aus wirtschaftlicher perspektive
und der frage was macht das mit unserer
gesellschaft ich sage ganz ehrlich als
ich gelandet bin letzte woche ende
letzter woche hatte ich das gefühl bei
vielen deutschen
wird weniger über das leid der ukraine
nachgedacht sondern sehr viel
mittlerweile darüber korrigieren sie
mich was das ganze
kostet also was sozusagen auf den
einzelnen zu kommen was den spritpreis
angeht was einen möglichen gas preis
angeht stegner wie nehmen sie das wahr
also ich finde das völlig unangemessenes
leiter menschen die im krieg adressen zu
vergleichen mit der schwierigkeit das
sage ich mal vorweg das sind andere
ebenen trotzdem ist natürlich richtig
dass wenn wir sanktionen machen das ziel
ja sein muss dass sie die anderen seite
mehr vernetzen als uns selbst wenn wir
als beispiel nehmen beispiel was auf
kritisiert wird die gaslieferung von
heute auf morgen einstellen würden also
würde aufhören mit dem gas was wir
brauchen würde uns industriegesellschaft
in wesentlichen teilen zusammenbrechen
das sagen an alle fachleute der putin
würde sich die händler in der würden
extra wodka darauf nehmen glaubt alle
fachleute ist mein verein durch und mai
sind die meisten sagen dass und mancher
ratschläge sind wohlfeil und die die
jetzt große reden halten wir müssen
jetzt mal den gürtel enger schnallen
sind meistens die den gürtel enger
schnallen kann und deswegen müssen wir
uns bei allen unterschied des leids wie
das ausdrücklich betonen schon darauf
achten dass nicht die menschen die
ohnehin schon am wenigsten haben sich
nicht mehr leisten können die
energiekosten zu bezahlen hat aber die
rechnung nicht vergessen die leute sagen
was du hast da haben sie recht wobei ich
hinzufügen möchte die nutznießer wenn
wir das ignorieren sind ja nicht die
menschen der ukraine sondern das sind
diese rechtsradikalen von nach dem
parlament die dann sofort wieder
auftritt gegen seinen kopf diese
demokratischen parteien noch meine angst
verliert die auf die wahlen wenn wir die
land das nicht machen wir haben jetzt
drei verschiedenen landes waren gaben
sondern haben wir prima gewonnen ich war
schon heftig verloren in nrw muss man
mal gucken was geht ab ist über die auf
die geräte aber er hat wenn sie das
hören von ralf stegner manchmal erkennt
man das gar nicht aber seine partei ist
ja in der bundesregierung weil
eigentlich könnten sich dann ja schon
ein bisschen mehr tun können wenn sie
sagen das ist dass leute haben noch
große hilfsaktion sie dann kann ich auch
sagen die cdu soll den angela merkel in
der spd gewesen wäre seit 15 jahren das
gibt es auch aber das noch alles quatsch
wir bemühen uns darum über uns mit mehr
steckt aber ein bisschen mehr konsens
als dass herr hat jetzt so tut dass wir
versuchen ja durchaus dinge gemeint und
so mal als der bundeskanzler geredet hat
von der zeitenwende da haben viele im
parlament gestellt
wir müssen raus aus der abhängigkeit von
lieferungen aus russland was über seine
gemeinsame fehler war den union und spd
gemeinsam begangen haben den korrigieren
wir jetzt schon mit der kritik immer
auch ein bisschen zurückhaltend zahlen
wenn man das hier so formuliert wir
kümmern uns darum das zu ändern und wir
müssen sie in einer form tun dass
normalverdiener und leute die nicht so
viel geld haben dabei nicht
überinvestiert werden weil diese zu
sagen sonst diese demokratie kann
gefährlich wird diese debatte auch am
ende für die unterstützung der ukraine
denn wenn der wirtschaftliche druck
zunimmt wenn die menschen das gefühl
haben das schadet ihnen ich habe so ein
bisschen das gefühl bekommen dass viele
kannst jetzt nicht nur mehrere schlagen
aber so ein bisschen das argument geben
jetzt muss auch mal schluss sein jetzt
auch genug mit krieg und die ukraine
soll sich jetzt mal ein tisch sitzen und
aufhören denn ich will nicht dass meine
meine preise weiter nach oben gehen wie
nehmen sie das wahr also ich habe jetzt
zunächst mal in den letzten zehn wochen
beobachtet dass viele von denen oder
alle diese befürchtung die auch anfangs
vorgetragen wurden was werden die
menschen sagen mit so viele flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine kommen was werden die
menschen sagen wenn durch diese die die
sanktionen die energiepreise steigen
dass sich das nicht bewahrheitet hat und
dass wir in deutschland doch da extrem
breite solidarität haben und dass die
menschen bereits in vieles zu ertragen
und das finde ich einfach ein schönes
zeichen von solidarität unser land fehlt
an dieser frage nicht auseinander
sondern im gegenteil ich glaube wir
stehen mehr zusammen und nicht zuletzt
im bundestag ja auch in der mitte des
hauses zwischen der regierung und der
cdu csu fraktion zu vielen gemeinsamen
entscheidungen gekommen und das soll
auch so bleiben ich glaube dass das
richtig ist dass wir den gashahn nicht
unsererseits abdrehen sollten weil im
grunde geht es ja darum fließt geld in
die russische kriegskasse die
kriegskasse ist aber gut gefüllt und
wenn wir das jetzt stoppen würden würde
das nicht bedeuten dass putin den kampf
reduzieren müsste das hätte eine
langfristigere wirkung dies vielleicht
auch wünschenswert aber sie würde keine
konkrete auswirkung auf den kampf haben
ich finde die technischen sanktionen die
wir machen wo technologie sanktionen
viel wirksam herr ernst wir hatten
letzte woche im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie den ich leite
eine debatte einig selbst befassung um
die frage wirkung von sanktionen gegen
russland auf wirtschaftlicher art oder
auch wirtschaft wirtschaftliche folgen
von boykotten maßnahmen ist im ergebnis
dasselbe wenn wir sagen wir nehmen ihn
kein gas mehr oder die russen liefern
kann ich ja da war die gasindustrie
vertreten da war zum beispiel auch die
stahlindustrie vertreten da war da waren
vertreter von verbänden wie man
geschickt haben und diese ergebnisse
beim gas innerhalb kürzester zeit wären
wir nicht mehr in der lage den
produktionsstandort deutschland in
schach zu halten das tatsächlich die
menschen ihr geld weiter verdienen und
wir haben jetzt schon auswirkungen auf
die preise sind allein dass wir darüber
reden die natürlich über das was man
vorher schon hatten weit hinaus können
heute hat ausgerechnet die amerikanische
finanzministerium gesagt wir sollen uns
dieses mal überlegen mit dem ölberg und
warum weil damit die ölpreise weiter
explodieren und im ergebnis das haben
uns auch die experten in unserer
anhörung gesagt im ergebnis könnte ich
sogar sein dass russland davon
profitiert weil durch die gesteigerten
durch die gesteigerte ölpreis ist nach
vorschlag die einnahmen die einnahmen
weiter steigen und das ziel erreicht ist
also vertritt würde versorgung mit den
maßnahmen die wir dort auch mit dem dass
wir dauernd sagen die russen sollen
gefälligst die verträge einhalten und
wir machen selber nimmer das ist
natürlich ein schlechtes argument
von rechts kommen immer die idee kommen
kaum konzentrieren doch haben das glaube
ich aber immer dieses projekt haben wir
immer das problem dass wir mit diesen
maßnahmen tatsächlich eher und selber
treffen und da da ist es leichter wenn
man an der oberen einkommen skala ist
als die die auf der unter den
einkommensskala sind das zu verkraften
bei die sims die die jobs verlieren wenn
die zulieferteile fehlen weil man kein
gar weiß ich möchte bei der totalen
vorschlag zustimmt hier habe ich
verstanden sie wollen zähler ich würde
zöllner auf importe aus russland für
energie erheben und dieses geld
abschöpfen um damit die schwachen zu
stützen dann würden wir einen teil
dieses enormen gewinns den putin
tatsächlich ein pferd durch die hohen
preise abschöpfen
die finde ich eigentlich die beste ich
würde ja noch einmal ein oberst viele
befragen was meinen sie und vor allem
wie strategisch wichtig ist um kriegs
diese zu erreichen
die frage von sanktionen und wie
erfolgreich ist aus ihrer sicht der
westen oder nicht erfolgreich
wir sind ja wenn man das auch bio
politischer ebene sieht also zusammen
auch über russland hinaus schaut aber
auch muss dann mit einbezieht in einem
geopolitischen wettbewerb um prosperität
und macht und einfluss und sollte
deutschland ist natürlich nicht gut
beraten sich in so einer phase zu
sprechen auch mit blick auf die
bundeswehr werde ich das sagen darf sie
steht ja im grunde bis auf die unterhose
entkleidet da und mich wundert schon
dass jetzt zwei monate nach kriegsbeginn
immer noch nichts wir eigentlich
passiert um sie wieder zu stärken
munitions bestehende systeme zu
beschaffen zu lassen das könnte eine
ministerin entschuldigung ein heute noch
in diesem monat beschlossen vom
parlament die union mit macht darüber
reden wir 2000 sie eigentlich gerne
verteidigungsminister und den job von
ford übernehmen oder die liebevoll
lamprecht shape sind die gerade mal 140
tage im amt ist die sollten mal gucken
was sie da hinterlassen haben wenn sie
denn werden sie mit dem heli da und den
kindern nach zurückgeflogen oder meine
oma weder der senat muss also was
diskutiert werde jetzt für dinge ja
schließlich eine
frage der hengst kiefer und sie
diskutieren wir schon die rentiere 7 ist
schon sehr wichtig denn die frage ob die
ministerin und süchtig ob die ministerin
diesen job der ja so wichtig ist wie
lange nicht mehr wirklich kann wissen
sie warum was ich glaube warum die
christine lambrecht zu hart kritisiert
sind mein eindruck ist sie wird
einerseits von denen kritisiert die
selbst das verteidigungsministerium
jahre lang geführt haben und ziemlich
hinterlassen fahrzeuge die nicht
verhandlung solche die nicht fliegen
schiffe die nicht seetauglich sind wir
haben eine nachmeldung ist eine schande
das bringen wir jetzt in ordnung mit dem
sondervermögen dass der eine punkt und
der zweite punkt sind in verdacht hat
bisher der vorname bricht muss aufhören
muss aufräumen mit dem beschaffungs
chaos mit den teuren beratern verträge
dieser gegeben das ist natürlich manchen
leuten ein großes dorn im auge die gerne
geld verdienen möchten das ist der grund
warum von lamberti hat bislang noch nie
gehört
ja die sondierungsgespräche der vor der
am ende der letzten vor der letzten
regierungsbildung geführt mit herr
mützenich und lars klingbeil das waren
unsere counterparts und wir haben
diskutiert über die finanzausstattung
der bundeswehr und es war nicht mehr zu
machen als 15 prozent vom bibb das haben
wir immerhin erreicht wir haben von 30
auf 50 milliarden die ausgaben
ausgeweitet aber die spd martin schulz
war damals noch der verhandlungsführer
der spd bundestagskandidat haben wir wir
waren bei 15 und das war der deckel und
mehr war nicht drin und die hätten gerne
mehr gemacht
ich hab ich hab's wegen heute eine
meldung gesehen und als ich wusste dass
sie kam habe ich mich gefragt ob
ihnen das auch durch den kopf geht und
ich weiß gar nicht haben sie eigentlich
gedient campino hat jetzt gesagt wenn
die situation heute so wäre das eher
entscheiden müsste aber zum wehrdienst
geht oder nicht zum wehrdienst geht dann
würde sich heute wahrscheinlich für den
wehrdienst entscheiden sie auch ich
nicht aber ich würde gerne noch was zu
den rüstungsausgaben
ich würde das nicht machen sie keine
sorge nein keinesfalls und die hörten
wir sehen hier einmal das getan würde da
jetzt hört er gerne über diese frage
noch mal reden wollen die nato gibt
zurzeit
1,15 millionen pro jahr für rüstung aus
die nato
russland und china zusammen 360
milliarden also wir haben eine mehr als
dreifache überlegenheit der nato
gegenüber dem potenziellen gegnern also
am geld kann sowohl am geld und wer wie
die nato und das ich auf und setzen ihr
kommen das wäre und die regierungen auch
die ihr haben wir offensichtlich linke
wichtige kriegt dieses geld so effektiv
einzusetzen dass zumindestens unterhosen
da sind wir ja hier das ist doch absurd
sie tun ja so als hätten sie als wären
es als wären sie die die die
überfliegerin der rüstungspolitik
gewesen hätten nie post damit zu tun
gehabt und beschweren sich jetzt in der
lage das geld vernünftig aussehen das
geld vernünftig einsetzen dann brauchen
wir uns über möglicherweise mehr geld
gar nicht unterhalten ja aber darüber
gibt es ja konsens unter den parteien
der mitte dass wir mehr geld für die
bundeswehr brauche zunächst die debatte
gezogen
die dreifach überlegenheit nicht in
milliarden brauchen wir
ja wir haben ein defizit von 480 wenn
ich das mal offen dafür also das ist
doch etwas angespannter 400 den
vergangenen jahren jahrhundert mineralen
aktion mitmacht und mit den taktischen
spielereien aufhörten abbekommen dürfen
dann kriegen wir noch in diesem monat
hin und dann werden sie sehen ist das
jahr an unserer europäischen verbündeten
weist auch unseren verbündeten verlassen
sich ja darauf dass wir etwas können ja
also diese nacktheit die schadet ja
nicht nur uns deutschen haben sie hat
also ich nehme einen großen konsens war
außer herrn ernst was die frage angeht
der finanzierung der bundeswehr das
nämlich als einigkeit ich schließlich
bewusst aus weil sie wollen ja auch
nicht dienen wie campino jetzt dienen
möchte
für die einschätzung der lage notwendig
so leider das ist leider leider ist die
leitung war eine diskussion heute um die
ukraine kriegen und der frage
eigentlich bin ich
ja sagen gemischt bei klaus ernst und
ich bedanke mich bei jürgen hardt und
ich glaube sie haben noch ein bisschen
was auszudiskutieren nach der sendung
herzlichen dank das war es viertel nach
acht bei der muss ja hier fährt der
schlagzeilen macht und ralf stegner sagt
er war heute der friedfertig sste ich
weiß nicht
[Musik]